[Music]
foreign
it's great to be back at GDC
you know back in 2020 as the pandemic
was ramping up we were the last major
company to drop out of GDC we're the
first to go all remote and then we
headed into the pandemic it was a
completely crazy time with thousands of
people working from around their homes
but the company thrived and so I'd like
to go through some of the things that
we've done since the since the last GDC
first of all we launched project Liberty
epic challenge the App Store monopolies
yeah we're in front of the ninth Circuit
Court Europe has passed major new
legislation and the fight goes on for
the freedom of all Developers
mediatonic joined epic launched Fall
Guys for free and brought in 60 million
new players
bandcamp the Indie music site joined
epic bandcamp helps Indie musicians
reach fans online today and we're going
to build metaverse opportunities for all
musicians in the future
fortnite Thrive during this time we
launched two major chapters lots of
seasons and brought the fortnite
audience up to 500 million player
accounts
Travis Scott launched the astronomical
concert into fortnite
Ariana Grande launched the rifter
and so overall fortnite had a really
great time with tons and tons of players
enjoying and the world constantly
evolving
we also learned some hard lessons Epic
into a massive settlement with the FTC
it really brought home to us and to the
whole industry that kids in technology
are a pressing topic for all developers
to take seriously and that the
expectations of regulators here in the
United States and around the world are
much higher than ever before
and so we've done a lot over the past
few years to improve things we've had
huge sets of new parental controls into
fortnite and the epic games store and
new child safety features like cabin
accounts
and being epic when we solve a problem
for ourselves we like to bring it to all
other developers so they can benefit
from the work and to that end super
awesome joined epic super awesome makes
verifiable parental consent tools they
are available to all Developers for free
so it becomes much easier to comply with
all the regulatory laws around
children's access to games worldwide
we also launched Unreal Engine 5 into
Early Access during the pandemic we went
through a year yes
went through a year of Early Access
followed by release we updated fortnite
to Unreal Engine 5 and then we spent a
whole year visually upgrading fortnite
to the latest capabilities of Unreal
Engine 5 and which we launched late last
year and we'll be showing later in this
show
epic game store also thrived the player
base has grown massively during this
time to over 230 million players on PC
um we've uh paid out more than a billion
dollars to all developers and we've also
just very recently launched
self-publishing so it's easier than ever
before to launch your game to all
customers in the PC market with really
straightforward tools and earn 80 88 of
all revenue
but that's a summary of the past and the
stay of unreal is about the future so
I'd like to invite Nick Penn Warden to
come up and talk about Unreal Engine 5.2
thanks
all right
thank you Tim
thanks Tim and hi everyone I'm excited
to get to show you some of the new
experimental features we've been working
on for Unreal Engine 5.2
let's take a look
[Music]
all right so last year we added several
new features to the engine to support
foliage rendering and the fortnite team
used those features to ship battle
royale chapter 4. at the same time Jacob
over there and the team at qixel were
experimenting with what's possible for
photoreal foliage environments as well
as testing out the latest functionality
that we've been building for Unreal
Engine
so Jacob's here with us today in the
unreal editor let's explore the
environment and what better way to do
that than off-roading and what better
way to off-road than an arivian r1t
now rivian uses unreal to power their
instrument cluster including 3D
visualization of their vehicles so we
worked with them to bring the r1t to
life in this experience
let's head on out Jacob sure thing on my
way all right so we're building tools
for interactive and dynamic worlds so
here we have chaos physics simulating
rocks that tumble as we drive over them
leaves Bend out of the way and we also
added some real-time fluid simulation
we worked with the team at rivien to set
up unreal's chaos vehicle model to
simulate the suspension of the truck and
how the electric motors Drive each
individual wheel
chaos also simulates how the tires
compress and deform and meta sounds
enabled the team to precisely
re-synthesize the sounds of the electric
motors and mix them with the ambisonics
of the jungle
so rivien provided us with a highly
detailed model of the truck about 71
million polygons that were able to
render in real time thanks to nanite
now the rivian not only looks incredibly
realistic because of lumen and nanite
but also its materials and today we're
introducing substrate our new material
framework
and the better demonstrate it let's swap
the paint out for opal
now of course you can't order a rivian
with opal body panels but opal was the
internal code name for this project and
also a really great demonstration of
substrate's capabilities
the base layer models the iridescence
refraction and Reflections that occur
inside of an opal and on top of that is
a layer representing the polished
surface and how light is absorbed as it
travels through that clear layer of
varying depth
and now we can add back on the dust and
dirt layers
and notice how the reflection changes
when interacting with the dust layer and
that there are no artifacts along the
transition from dirt to dust to opal
so substrate is more expressive enabling
artists to create materials like this
with different shading models and
compose and layer those materials as
they see fit
all right let's uh head on out Jacob on
my way
in terms of performance substrate
materials that are similar to the
current Unreal Engine shading model cost
about the same but now artists have the
freedom to author more complex materials
for extremely detailed use cases like in
cinematics and in film
so we're going to drive under this
fallen tree here and everything that
you've seen up to this point was
painstakingly hand built by the
environment team at quixel everything
since that fallen tree has been built
using our brand new experimental Suite
of procedural content generation tools
entirely an engine that are flexible
deterministic and artist driven our
guiding principle in building these
systems was to empower artists to make
tools for artists
so Jacob's going to go ahead and add a
procedural assembly to the world
and the cool thing is that it
communicates
thank you
yeah
pretty cool
and the cool thing is that it
communicates with other nearby
procedural elements in the scene like
the creek bed so let's say a designer
comes by wants to direct the player to
drive to the left Jacob can simply move
the assembly to the right and everything
updates to accommodate that change
game design is iterative so let's say
the designer comes back wants to give
the player the choice of going left or
right again Jacob can simply move the
assembly back over
now the artist who created this assembly
also added some additional handles that
Jacob can use to Art direct where Rock
slides occur allows them to customize
the piece a little bit more make it a
little easier for the ravian to drive by
so we started by hand crafting that
original part of the level to set the
visuals in art direction for the entire
piece and then built out procedural
tools that allowed the team to create a
much larger play Space much more quickly
now let's see how we can use these
procedural tools to make larger sweeping
changes to the environment
so Jacob let's start by removing some of
the trees in this area absolutely that's
easy enough actually
all right a little too much let's let's
add some trees back in okay and let's
also add in some Cliff formations give
it a little bit more variability
so the procedural systems are all
deterministic as Jacob is experimenting
with different sets of input parameters
once he finds a set that he likes he can
always go back to it and get out exactly
the same results
and the procedural systems aren't just
placing trees and rocks but also fog
cards bugs birds everything that's
needed to bring this environment to life
and everything that you've seen here
works at scale this environment is four
kilometers by four kilometers
if we hide all the procedural elements
we can see that original hand-built area
about 200 meters by 200 meters
we believe that there will always be the
need for hand building environments so
we design these procedural systems to be
tools for artists that work in concert
with hand-built content
both substrate and the new procedural
tools will be available in experimental
form in 5.2
and everything you've seen here is
running in the unreal editor in real
time on a developer machine with an
Intel 13900k CPU and Nvidia RTX 4090 GPU
so Jacob thanks for being here and
helping us out today thank you very much
Nick for having me it's been a pleasure
all right so come visit us at the Unreal
Engine booth on the Expo floor you can
check out this demo for yourself and
this afternoon here in the ybca we'll
have a tech talk diving into the details
behind this demo
in addition the preview one build of
Unreal Engine 5.2 is available now you
can test out all of the experimental new
features we showed today as well as
numerous other improvements head over to
the epic game store to download the
binary build and also get the full
source code from the Unreal Engine
repository on GitHub
I found that we make the best technology
for developers when we use it ourselves
when we really put the engine through
its Paces both through Tech demos like
this one as well as full game
Productions so to talk about how the
fortnite team used the latest Unreal
Engine 5 capabilities to ship battle
royale chapter 4. please help me welcome
John laugh
[Applause]
thanks Nick
for chapter four we wanted to show
fortnite in a way players had never seen
before
we upgraded with broad Strokes using
Lumen nanite and other ue5 Tech
we work directly with the engine team to
improve these features and ensure they
scaled on all platforms fortnite ships
on
first up was lighting now our options in
the past to improve lighting have been
somewhat limited because fortnite is a
really Dynamic game
big lighting just doesn't work because
the moment a player destroys a wall
light maps are invalidated
so we were really excited to give Lumen
a shot
it updates Global Illumination in real
time as the environment changes
early in chapter 4 development we
captured a video of lumen enabled in a
fortnight test build and the player in
the video destroyed a wall and light
just came flooding into the room
and honestly it was pretty stunning it
brought new life to the environment and
the realistic bounce light worked great
with fortnite's vibrant Style
well initial results were exciting you
know nothing is that easy in Game Dev
and as we discovered Real World Lighting
can create real world problems
play tests revealed areas of the map
like attics and basements that had no
windows and were just too dark for
gameplay
and it was also the first time we were
using Auto exposure and it was causing
bloomed out areas when players were in
dark Interiors looking outside
we solved these issues using ue5
features like local exposure and some
art directable controls within lumen
that enabled us to provide a final image
much better for gameplay
while the art team refined content the
engine team provided some new
scalability options so that we could run
Lumen on next-gen consoles at 60 frames
per second
in addition to lighting nanite opened
the door for us to add an incredible
amount of detail to the fortnite island
it was introduced in ue5 as a
virtualized geometry system that
supports extreme mesh complexity
so we spent some time experimenting
looking for a good balance between
stylized art Direction and detail
so we could increase visual quality but
still maintain fortnite's iconic Style
now that artists weren't limited by
triangle counts we scaled our content
pipelines to support Nana on high-end
Hardware
Tech artists model new vegetation assets
and the art team created some high
detailed props and some amazing hero
assets
but this still left us with the large
building library that needed a visual
upgrade
we resolved this using an offline
process that took displacement maps from
our materials
and created high resolution nanite
meshes
it was really cool to see these Classic
fortnite Materials like brick stone and
wood get a high resolution facelift and
pop off their surfaces
now past the United demos have relied on
static hard surface environments but
fortnite's an animated World trees blow
in the wind and buildings wobble when
hit
so we worked with the Nani team and they
extended the material pipeline to
include masked and animated materials on
Nano geometry
the island and fortnite is constantly
evolving with major changes each season
and complete reboots when chapters
launch so it's essential that we evolve
our workflows too
during chapter 4 development we started
utilizing two new ue5 features that
changed how we build levels World
partition and one file per actor
World partition automates the level
streaming and it allowed us to work in
one large level
we use level instance actors to group
content logically like a building and
all of its props
one file per actor ensured our large Dev
team could work in this space without
Source control conflicts
now these features hadn't yet been put
to their Paces by a large Dev team so
there were some early bumps in the road
but rlds were in Daily communication
with the engine team and we saw
consistent improvements not long into
production we were developing fortnite
in a much more collaborative environment
our goal for chapter four was to deliver
an awesome experience to our players
but we also hope by using and improving
the engine's newest features we've
improved your experience as well
now with the look with a look at the
amazing work developers are already
doing in ue5 please welcome Dana Cowley
foreign
[Applause]
tools and amazing content at your
fingertips making games is hard and it
gets even trickier when you're trying to
ship while you're upgrading your
features and we put a lot of effort into
making sure that the trans the um the
transition from ue4 to ue5 was as smooth
as possible and you've proven that it
worked and we've been impressed with all
the teams who have made the jump ever so
quickly you know many of you moved your
games over right in the middle of
development and quite a few of you have
left internal Tech in favor of ue5 and
as of last month 77 percent of all
unreasoned users are on ue5 and that's
rapid adoption and Mass
and over 750 000 of you are actively
building with Unreal Engine each and
every month
you've invested in us and we're
investing in you
and Beyond games you're telling Amazing
Stories across live action and animated
entertainment and to date more than 550
television film projects have been made
with Unreal Engine in production
now these are some of the leading
Studios using ue5 today
this represents a Brain Trust of
talented game developers from all over
the world and it's getting bigger every
day
you have validated that we're on the
right path and we're blown away by how
you've embraced the tools and shown us
what's possible
and now you're about to hear from
several talented teams who are bringing
their awesome games to PC console and
mobile
first up we have qubit Studios a small
team whose game infinite testicles has
not only received an epic Mega Grant but
it's also coming to the epic game store
with the help of Epic Games publishing
here to give you an exclusive New Look
is Michael forzard
hi everyone
I was invited here today to share our
story with you QB Studios is a small
Studio from Europe
and we have one mission to bring the
world of infinitesimals to life
in our first game you play as Captain
orkney rolling rig as yani's crew
explore a mysterious planet filled with
large environments
now a universe is already big at our
scale but when your main character is
only a few millimeters tall it takes on
a wall new meaning
as a studio we have big ideas as a small
team we need to make choices and that's
where switching from uv4 to ua5 made a
big difference for us it has empowered
Us by giving us time back
let me take you through a few examples
is very small we want players to truly
feel a sense of scale by having a large
space to explore by using wall partition
in ue5 we managed to save month of death
time not just because of the size of the
world but also because we can build on
top of it it allowed us to specialize a
lot of systems very quickly
and with the built-in H lab we get
strong runtime performance while being
able to load the entire world visually
in editor
a large world is great but it doesn't do
us any good if it's empty and that's
where the new pack actors and level
instances came in handy
a level designer can use prefabs to
quickly prototype ideas while artists
can refine those prefabs in editor by
assembling assets together
and with one file per actor it all
happens in parallel
on the animation side motion warpings
allows us to use a single animation for
a large range of situations and with
control rig we can quickly create those
first pass animations in editor
but the most outstanding features on a
knight and lumen
we don't need to spend time on topology
optimization and can directly use hyper
images lighting is more realistic and we
don't have to use tricks for transition
between exterior and interior
all in all working with V5 has been a
tremendous time server for us and
upgrading from B4 was surprisingly easy
we were up and running in a couple of
days
we can know iterate more quickly focus
on gameplay and allocate time to riskier
ideas
but enough talking go on the epic game
store and wishlist the game now
thank you everyone enjoy the rest of the
show
your team has built a beautiful game
Michael fantastic work now our next
partner is one that needs little
introduction Kabam develops and
publishes world-class highly social
multiplayer mobile games and today they
are here to make a special announcement
please join me in welcoming vice
president of product Tyler black
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Dina for that kind
introduction hi everyone at Kabam we've
worked with the world's biggest brands
and created our own stories to bring
some of the most successful mobile games
to players
today we're proud to announce a new
project
one that ushers in a whole new era for
Kabam
King Arthur Legends rise
it's a new cross-platform Squad RPG set
in a stunning reimagined Arthurian world
when we began this ambitious project we
knew that Unreal Engine was the only
solution that had the tools to bring
incredible visuals to both mobile and PC
at launch so here's how we put those
tools to use
King Arthur Legends rise allows players
to explore campaign stages and interact
with their environment using a variety
of animations
if we were to use traditional animation
techniques
the number of assets that we would need
would be massive
thanks to unreal's Advanced animation
technology like ik rig retargeting
motion warping and property access we
can create high quality detailed and
attractive animations with relatively
few resources
but that isn't the only way that we're
using Unreal Engine 5's tools to deepen
the player experience
we're also making use of dynamic weather
to affect character strengths and other
stats and keep the battle gameplay fresh
and immersive
that's all from us today
we can't wait to share more with you
about King Arthur Legends rise in the
coming months so check out our website
playkingarthur.com and sign up to stay
up to date on our newest game
thanks Tyler
now the next developer coming to the
stage was founded a few years ago and
they're already making a big name for
themselves hexworks is a CI game studio
and they are capturing the imaginations
of fans of Dark Fantasy with their new
action RPG Lords of the Fallen
creative director Cesar bitosu is here
to give you an exclusive look at how
they're using ue5 to build one of this
year's most highly anticipated games
thank you Dana thank you Dana for the
introduction and handling my name so
graciously
hello everyone I am very excited to be
here and represent hexworks our
incredibly talented multinational team
behind Lords of the Fallen our upcoming
dark fantasy action RPG and today we'll
be sharing how Unreal Engine 5 has
helped bring our highly ambitious and
decidedly Grim Vision to life please
enjoy
welcome to the Lords of the Fallen
technical showcase
here at hexworks our goal has always
been to create the most immersive game
experience possible
today we're journeying to Sky rest
Bridge one of the game's early locations
to demonstrate just some of the
impressive ways Unreal Engine 5's
state-of-the-art technologies have
helped us deliver on this ambitious
vision for our upcoming action RPG
we want players to feel fully immersed
in our world by playing as their own
unique virtual persona to achieve this
we've used a combination of Technologies
including 3D scans of real people and
ue5's own character customization Tech
players can create unique faces and
bodies by dynamically morphing between a
huge range of shapes before finessing
the finer details
our extensive selection of armor sets
seamlessly adapt to whatever shape the
player chooses it's really important to
us that we represent as wide a
proportion of our audience as possible
being able to customize your hero and
Lords of the Fallen is only the
beginning
each and every one of our characters is
incredibly detailed using high
resolution textures
get up close to any surface in the game
like this tunic for example and detail
texturing provides incredible levels of
micro detail
how these objects move and behave is
also crucial for player immersion ue5's
chaos physics engine facilitates
Advanced simulations for clothes chains
air belts and a whole lot more this
helps to substantially enhance the
secondary Motion in all our characters
making their movements look much more
lifelike
[Music]
the lighting in Lords of the Fallen
takes full advantage of unreal's brand
new Lumen GI we've been able to light
our complex environments in real time
meaning we can immediately see the
effect of a light bounce for example
without waiting for the traditional slow
baking processes watch how the lighting
reacts as we move our light source
around this environment
Global illumination like this can be
quite demanding on processing so we also
make use of emissive shapes to add
additional details to the lighting of
any space we can then fine-tune these
light bounces on our nanite meshes
providing our world with impressive
levels of detail and minimal impact on
performance
perhaps the most important element of
Lords of the Fallen is the ability to
travel between two worlds a realm of the
living Axiom and the realm of the Dead
umbrella
we've created our own custom tool set
within ue5 it allows us to intricately
craft these two environments side by
side and seamlessly swap between them
this means our artists and designers can
ensure these worlds feel intrinsically
linked like two sides of the same coin
even if one side is decidedly more
horrific than the other
on behalf of hexworks thanks for
watching today's brief Tech presentation
the twin Realms of umbral and Axiom
await Fearless adventurers later this
year when Lords of the Fallen Launches
on PC and current gen consoles
looking awesome thank you
this next team is known for making some
of the world's most popular
MMORPGs and recently they've been
pushing the boundaries of cinematic
storytelling and the results speak for
themselves
here with more is ncsoft's Chief
strategy officer Dr song Yi Yoon
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much for the introduction
Dana
good morning everyone
I'm excited to share our latest
production Project M with you today
you may know
ncisoft is recognized as one of the best
MMORPG developers thanks to our
Blockbuster franchises like lineage and
Guild Wars
however
we're not content with this achievement
we're always pushing for boundaries and
exploring new technologies
so let me introduce project MTU
it is our latest Innovation harnessing
the power of Cutting Edge Ai and
Graphics technology to an unprecedented
level
with help of Unreal Engine we have
achieved our vision for Project M with
seamlessly integrating
our foundational AI technology resulting
in breathtaking detail
so to give you a sneak peek we have
prepared a video
featuring our CEO and chief creative
officer TJ
who will personally guide you through
our newest creation as a digital version
of himself
thank you so much for your attention and
I hope you enjoy Project M
[Music]
foreign
project in is one of ncsoft's most
ambitious projects today
[Music]
what would it mean to you if the world
was comprised of informational articles
instead of physical particles
oh I got a little ahead of myself I am
TJ Kemp from ncsoft
welcome to project him
[Music]
how are the fabric of simulated reality
changed our Pursuit world if we could
tamper with the arrangement of those
particles
very idea is what sparked Project M
M
the informational particles that shape
project M's world can transform reality
based on your choices
and each choice you make will change
your experience
[Music]
the information that exists in the
present reality determines how the world
will unfold
[Music]
value every encounter and every moment
these will be essential in the world of
project and
this is where our journey ends from now
I look forward to seeing you all again
soon
[Music]
thank you Dr Yin Project M is looking
amazing and it's unlike anything we've
seen
and thanks to all the teams that have
given us a new look at your incredible
games
like we just saw the world's year
building
these are awesome looking characters
with loads of detail and authenticity
and our team understands that believable
digital humans are at the heart of great
storytelling and for more on that I'm
happy to hand it over to our CTO Kim
Larry
thank you
some incredible games to hi everybody
wow it's great to be back after four
years
um it's good to see you all
um so it's been two years since we
released metahuman Creator This Cloud
hosted tool allows you to create
photorealistic digital humans for your
game or experience with the Simplicity
of an RPG character creator
yet with a level of realism and
customization that you've never seen
before
our community has created millions of
metahumans for their unreal projects and
the work we've seen has been
unbelievably breathtaking and I'm sure a
bunch of you in the audience actually
making better humans as well let's take
a look at some of this work
thank you
amazing you know there isn't a day that
so there isn't a day that goes by that
we don't see some post on LinkedIn or
Facebook or wherever showing us amazing
usage of metahumans and I think it's
been a really big game changer for
anybody trying to tell a story in their
game or their experience
um but today we want to take things to
the next level so I'm going to actually
introduce two of my most favorite
friends
um to the stage our head of digital
human technology Vladimir masilovich and
the actress best known as senua from
Ninja theories fantastic hellblade
series Melina Jurgens how are you both
doing well thank you it's been a while
since we were last on the stage in fact
I think it was seven years ago that we
went through this audio that's a long
time ago triggering there but it was the
first time we all came together Ninja
Theory epic cubic motion free lateral to
do something that we thought would wow
audiences here and sort of set a
template for the future of using
characters in games so anyway
um I think we're uh I think we're in a
pretty good pretty amazing place right
now with the industry but we do want to
take things to the next level and what I
want to do a little bit bit about is how
things go into Ninja Theory how's that
how's the new game going yeah the team
and I are doing really good and we're
just extremely busy working on the
follow-up to the first hellblade which
will be called senua Saga held late too
I can't wait the first game was
fantastic thank you I really can't wait
to play it so get it out soon anyway I'm
Gonna Leave the stage and let these two
take over
go and blow people's minds thank you
hi everyone
our guiding vision for metahuman has
been the democratization of complex
character Technologies allowing you to
work faster and see the results
immediately
a character is only truly believable if
it's motion Fidelity matches its visual
Fidelity but animating at this level is
a hard task for even the most skilled
Studios
some of our best work leveraged 4D
capture but this took specialized
Hardware in weeks or even months of
processing time
while meta human creature gave you the
ability to generate high quality
characters
animating them still wasn't as easy
this is why I'm very excited to announce
a new capability to the metal human
product meta human animator
met the human animator contains the
essence of our 4D pipeline but optimized
to run on a single machine
it is able to use iPhone as well as
stereo professional systems and today
we're going to demonstrate how it works
for this we're going to need now our
technician John Cook and just the phone
now can you take your position please
sure
let me know when you're ready
okay and action
I need performance capture to work like
a mirror I needed to capture whether I'm
acting scared
or angry
and sometimes all I need is a look
cut thanks Mel that was great yeah
you're welcome
okay
our technician John is currently pulling
Mass performance from the phone onto his
machine where everything will be
processed locally
we have updated our live link face
mobile app to capture all data at the
best resolution possible with the device
better human animator uses video and Dev
data to convert this data into High
Fidelity performance animation and it
can even use audio to produce convincing
tongue animation
John is currently scrubbing through the
take to pick the section that he wants
to process
John are we all good with the data
awesome so from now on it's just a
single button click to kick off the
processing which for a performance of
this length will take less than a minute
to convert into animation
so Mel well that is processing let me
show you something else
oh is that me yeah this is what we refer
to as your meta-human DNA cool and this
is generated by the capture we made
earlier right yeah that's right so from
only three frames of video and that data
we can generate a rig that predicts all
of your facial expressions in just a
couple of minutes wow and do you only
need to do this once for each actor yes
that's right it calibrates the solver to
your face so that we can produce the
performance in in a way that faithful
reproduces the original performance it
sounds cool yeah so let's check back on
the on the processing which today is on
the latest CP and GPU Hardware from AMD
meta human animator uses a custom epic
facial solver and landmark detector
we can interactively look at Innovation
while it's being solved and compared to
your original performance
so it looks like it just it's almost
finished
after this is going to do one more pass
to make the curves more stable
it's really quick
and from here on
we can we just need to export the
animation this takes only a few seconds
and then John needs to drop it in the
level and add the audio so that we can
see the result
so Mouse meta human should now be ready
in the level well excited to see the
results yeah I can't wait to see it
I need performance capture to work like
a mirror I needed to capture whether I'm
acting scared
or angry
and sometimes all I need is a look
thank you all so Mel what do you think I
think it's incredible because it usually
takes months between performance capture
and getting any results back so this is
blowing my mind and all of this is sold
directly onto animator friend and
controls in this case we are using a
bespoke 4D rig which we created together
with Ninja Theory for hellblade 2 but
it's also ready to use on any meta human
or any other rig that follows our new
meta human standard
let's have a look at that
I need performance capture to work like
a mirror I needed to capture whether I'm
acting scared
or angry
and sometimes all I need is a look so
the same thing works even on stylish
characters
thank you all these Technologies are
completely redefining our creative
process as they already find yours One
release met a human animator to everyone
in just couple of months
we've got one more thing we'd like to
show you we haven't forgotten about the
needs for full performance capture
shoots what you're about to see is
animation that has not been polished or
edited in any way and it took meta human
animator just minutes to process start
to finish
it's one of my favorite lines from Ninja
Theory's upcoming
Saga helpline
very much thank you
so in Perth cut take 13.
foreign
[Music]
will destroy them
good you like it
[Applause]
[Music]
man was that cool
all right let's talk about the future of
our creator marketplaces we all know one
of the biggest challenges in game
development is the time and cost
associated with making great art and
Visually stunning environments
now we've seen that by giving you access
to high quality game-ready assets like
quixel Mega scans World building can be
faster more efficient and more
economical the resulting explosion of
creativity that we've seen from our
Unreal Engine developer Community has
been awesome
in fact it's inspired us to double down
on a mission that started several years
ago
since the launch of Unreal Engine
Marketplace in 2014 we've been working
to Aggregate and organized all the
world's best digital assets for you to
use in your work
in 2018 we joined forces with quixel
whose Mega scans have now been
downloaded over 40 million times
in 2021 art station became part of the
Epic family and we welcomed a community
of the world's best digital artists
who've since uploaded nearly 12 million
projects to the site
later that same year sketchfab joined
epic and now has more than 10 million
registered users who are using the
platform to discover
share and manage 3D models on the web
now each of these businesses has their
own unique superpowers incredible
content of course vibrant communities
and killer capabilities
we're now working to bring all this
together into a unified offering let's
take a look
[Applause]
good morning
[Music]
thank you
later this year we'll be merging our
content offerings into a new unified
creative Marketplace called Fab
built on the strong Foundation of
sketchfab.com we're going to drop the
sketch and go all in on Fab
will be an Open Marketplace serving the
entire digital content creation industry
that means we're going to offer assets
for all game engines All Digital content
creation tools and metaverse inspired
open worlds so whether you're a studio
making a blockbuster game or a movie or
your player building your first island
in fortnite our goal is to bring you
everything you need to build your world
in one place
we'll have 3D models material sound
plugins animations visual effects and
more
found me the new home of quixel Mega
scans metahumans and other incredible
epic content designed to push the limits
of what's possible
we'll also bring you the high quality
assets and environment packs from
leading art studios AAA game developers
media companies and even musicians who
are taking fan engagement to the next
level
but our primary focus is on bringing you
the best stuff out there from millions
of Independent Artists who will benefit
from the lowest fees in the industry
pocketing 88 percent of revenue from
their sales so they can build real
businesses and invest in making more
great assets for you to use
that's right
now with millions of assets we have to
make it super simple for you to find
what you're looking for and get inspired
along the way we'll leverage automated
tagging to consistently and accurately
describe content and will give you the
ability to inspect 3D models before you
download making it easy to understand
the game Readiness of an asset so there
are no surprises
building on the success of quixel bridge
the Fab plug-in will enable you to
search discover drag and drop content
right into your scene without leaving
the game editor
we want to we want to improve your
workflows by connecting Fab to All
industry-leading Digital content
creation tools for example our
partnership with Adobe will make it easy
for you to export and publish models
from Adobe substance painter directly to
Fab
and finally leveraging sketchfab's
digital Asset Management capabilities
Fab will be the place where you go to
store manage and share assets either
privately with teammates for
collaboration or publicly on the web to
Showcase your work
with collaboration tools like this we
want to help small teams do big things
now it's no longer just major Studios
who are driving our industry forward
World building has become accessible to
everyone and we're seeing this today
with tens of millions of new creators
building awesome experiences in fortnite
Roblox Minecraft and other open worlds
this is increasing the demand for ready
to use content and it's creating an
exciting new opportunity for asset
creators to reach massive new audiences
We Believe an open and fair marketplace
where artists and developers can come
together to buy and sell assets is
essential to the creation of the
emerging metaverse
now we're going to keep you posted over
the course of the next several months as
this rolls out and we're looking forward
to partnering with you all to make this
an industry-wide success and now please
welcome sax Pearson
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we've been working towards this moment
for a very long time
this next segment is exactly why I'm
here at Epic to move the industry
forward and help make developers
successful
I'm here to introduce powerful new tools
to existing fortnite creators powerful
new opportunities for professional
Developers
fortnite is becoming an ecosystem
that means new tools to design develop
and publish games and a new economy that
rewards Developers
these updates bring us one step closer
to epic's vision of a connected
metaverse with billions of players enjoy
high quality creations made by millions
of Developers
at the center of this all is unreal
editor for fortnite available today in
public beta on epic game store
it's a new pc application that brings
the power of Unreal Engine to the scale
of the fortnite audience
deeply integrated with the game with new
workflows that allow PC and all other
platforms to create together fast and
fluid we call it uefn for short
but first let's talk about how we got
here
fortnite changed when we released
fortnite creative four years ago
creative is an in-game toolkit for
players to make sandbox games inside
fortnite and because of creative
fortnite is already much more than a
game
it's already a place where players find
games and developers find players
but why should you develop in fortnite
well our players are highly social
content hungry with over 500 million
play accounts massive PC presents and
the largest console player base is the
best most vibrant place for developers
to find an audience quickly
and publish new games
Islands built using creative tools
already account for roughly 40 percent
of play time in fortnite that's billions
of hours a year and we expect that
number to keep growing with uefn
so this is a sample of games in fortnite
today
what we have noticed is that players are
more engaged they have more fun when
they play epic Zone games like Battle
Royale and Community games made by
creators like you like the combination
is what makes fortnite special and what
is going to help us all grow
as we've shown it on Wheel engine epic's
mission is to deliver an awesome Suite
of tools for developers on Wheel editor
for fortnite is for experienced game
developers like many are you in this
room but it's also for the growing
community of fortnite Island creators
that are ready for unreal engines proven
PC editor workflow
as you're going to see in the demo
coming up
uefn and the existing creative toolkit
is already a great combo for developer
and fortnite Creator teams to make
incredible experiences
of course a long-term goal is to make
the entire feature set of unveil engine
or bring the entire feature set of
unveilment into uefn but also over time
to expose many of the other services
that epic offers
build just announced Fab Fab is
launching today also inside uefn in an
alpha version and products like
metahuman will be coming to uefn in the
future to support your Creative Vision
for the next stage of fortnite and
ultimately the open metaverse we also
need brand new tools that solve really
hard problems interoperability
scalability and resilience a real issue
when you operate at this scale
and in expect this level of durability
this is what led us to develop verse
it's a powerful new general programming
language designed specifically for this
purpose you're going to see us use it in
the demo in just a moment
the second thing we're working towards
is high interoperability between uefn
and Unreal Engine that'll enable you to
take your work anywhere and
by the way behind me is the new Creator
portal also launching today where you
can manage all your Islands one click
publish them to the world and when you
publish the uefn your original Ip annual
assets are yours to take anywhere
now let's take a closer look at uefn
features and workflows we put together a
short video and then we're going to do a
demo thank you
let's start with the basics unreal
editor for fortnite runs on PC and is
integrated directly with fortnite so
you'll have access to over four years of
content all for free to get you started
what's special about uefn is what we
call live edit live edit allows anyone
on your team to join a uefn session from
any platform that runs fortnite that
means someone can join from a console
using the normal fortnite client and
they're able to work alongside and
collaborate with PC users
uefn has access to all fortnite creative
devices our modular gameplay systems
that work in the in-game editor this
allows you to instantly add gameplay and
quickly bootstrap your game from the
hundreds of gameplay devices already
available the uefn beta has many of the
same features we use to create fortnite
including the landscape editing tool set
you can edit the landscape to change the
look of your island or make sweeping
changes to create something completely
new and then quickly play it in game to
check out the results
so even though you have access to tons
of fortnite content with uefn you can
make content that looks nothing like
fortnite
this is a section from forest Guardian a
tech demo built in uefn that we are
launching today
a big feature of uefn is the ability to
import your own custom assets so we used
a few 3D models textures and materials
that we built just for the project
and all the lighting in the cave was
made possible thanks to Lumen our
real-time Global illumination system
you can also find more content like
quicksomega scans and sketchfab models
in our initial Alpha release of the Fab
plugin for uefn all assets are curated
and optimized for use in fortnite and
the full version of Fab will launch
later this year you can also create and
modify materials so you can change the
look and feel of objects easily and you
can import skeletal meshes and then
animate using sequencer and control rig
everything you've just seen is available
today in the public beta version of
unreal editor for fortnite
so it's a short video of just like the
most condensed way we could show
somebody in like the more important
workflows but I think a much better way
is to Temp fate and let's do a live demo
on PC running on fortnite public servers
right here on stage welcome Michael and
Ray to the stage
take it away
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm glad that went well
all right hey folks so let's talk about
how all this was made
Michael here has the scene open in
unreal editor so we can take a closer
look for the environment we built this
level using quixel Mega scan assets many
of which are available in the Fab uefn
plugin we also used custom content that
we built just for this demo
for the gameplay you just saw
we had we hand placed enemies using a
creative device called a guard spawner
which generates the aliens that you saw
at specific locations however we wanted
to do more and introduce Dynamic play
that goes beyond what the current
creative devices can do
so to do this we used our new
programming language called verse
so in this short section of code every
second we grab the position of the
player and for each spot location we
then calculate the distance to the
player and if it's within a certain
threshold we tell that guard to spawn
into the level
so we have gameplay that's more reactive
to those actions
this is just a short example of using
verse but for a deeper dive check out
the verse Tech talk later today
now Michael is going to show us how we
put the intro cinematic together hi
everybody so before the gameplay section
we played this a quick cinematic
animation this was actually created
entirely in uefn using sequencer
sequencers are multi-track editor and
it's been used in everything from
in-game cinematics to Hollywood feature
films so let's take a look uh now all of
the stuff is available right inside uafn
so let's take a look at this last shot
from a slightly different perspective so
the other thing we featured in this
section was a bunch of Niagara Niagara
is now available in uefn and it's our
high-end VFX system
so and just like in the movies you can
frame up shots and have great effects so
what we're going to do here is just set
this up
so just look at the movies you have slow
mode too makes everything better right
so this is just a sampling of some of
the stuff that you can do inside
sequencer but let's get back to the game
all right so now that we're back in the
game in uefn you have access to
fortnite's time of day system or you
could use what we did and do what we did
and use a completely custom lighting
solution and thanks to Lumen both
daytime and night time look great now
let's go to the final gameplay section
and let's close out the demo
but as a reminder everything that you're
seeing here was created in the same
version of uefn that we're releasing
today I think I'm gonna jump in here and
help you right I am all for that
thank you
[Applause]
thanks Michael and Ray anyone everybody
that put this together
the the demo came about when we asked
the special projects team inside epic
that came straight off the Matrix demo
to why don't you put uefn through its
paces and one amazing fact about this
demo is that it's less than 400 Megs it
downloads and plays in less than a
minute and it plays on any platform that
fortnite runs on like that is the
promise of what uafn is
so again unreal edit fortnite is
available today in public beta in epic
game store if you want an early glimpse
of some other technical showcases that
our internal teams made with uefn and
verse check out assertive domination
Forest guardian and the space inside all
three available to play right now in
fortnite discover
so we've talked about brand new tools in
the fortnite ecosystem now I want to
talk about the next generation of
fortnite's economy they're both epic and
creators will participate in
we call it Creator economy 2.0
here's how it works
the money in the economy comes from
player spending in the item shop
fortnite generates billions of dollars a
year in revenue from player purchases
fortnite players who have fun engaging
in Islands tend to spend more in the
item shop creators who make popular
islands are bringing real value to the
fortnite ecosystem and we're going to
share the resulting Revenue with them
this is the engine powering a Creator
economy 2.0
we believe this so strongly we will
distribute 40 percent of fortnite's
global net revenue to eligible creators
who publish games in fortnite both
independent developers and Epic
anything we make like Battle Royale zero
build all to participates in the pool
shared with creators this will be the
primary way that epic will pay for our
own game development in fortnite going
forward
thank you
I'm glad you feel it's a big deal that I
I feel exhibited
um this is this is transformative and a
big gut check for us too we imagine
thousands of third-party development
teams building businesses and thriving
with this model
payments from the pool are based on
performance of The Island we take into
account data like Island popularity
engagement retention attracting new
players
and the benefit of this new approach is
rooted in player fun and rewards
everyone's creative work both yours and
epics
there's no need to design cunning
monetization Loops or extractive gating
items you make an island that players
love that is all you need to be part of
the new economy
Creator economy 2.0 is live right now
for eligible creators who are currently
publishing
we are back dating the engagement
payouts to the beginning of this month
and for more details and to sign up go
to create.fortnite.com
everything you've seen today represents
epic's biggest bet ever the release of
advanced tools that publish directly
into fortnite on PC console mobile and
Cloud lowering the barrier for
developers to be part of one of the
biggest entertainment ecosystems
we welcome anyone to join us in the
future where Regional content is owned
by its creators where developer earnings
are function of fun and where ecosystem
can be directly linked through Community
language standards like verse
so support to support developers who
adopt uefn we're broadening the Epic
Mega grants program to help teams
bootstrap projects that use uefn and
verse
we're just getting started so we hope
that you'll join us and help shape the
future of development
now we're going to give you a look at
what uefn can do right inside fortnite
after the video Tim is going to come
back out to talk about epic's Future
Vision thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you
thanks we think this is going to be a
really powerful combination putting
together a fortnight 70 million monthly
active users with the power of the
unreal editor and a new Creator economy
to share the revenue with creators who
create engaging experiences and it's
another Milestone on the path to a new
kind of entertainment medium which
science fiction literature caused the
metaverse
because there's a crazy amount of hype
around this whole topic I'd like to step
back and take a long-term look at what
we see here
and the core of it is some very real
growth starting with fortnite 70 million
monthly active users Roblox is 250
million monthly active users Minecraft's
100 million and pubg mobile and Apex
Legends and numerous other metaverse
inspired games is leading to an
identifiable audience today of over 600
million active users in these Virtual
Worlds Antonia growth trajectory they
will put it at billions of users by the
end of this decade
and so he can set aside the crazy hype
cycle around nfts and VR goggles you
know these Technologies may play a role
in the future but they are not required
this revolution is happening right now
and the core of it is something every
gamer already understands it's you and
your friends getting together online and
going around as a group on voice chat
having a fun time and social
entertainment experiences and some of
these experiences are serious games like
Battle Royale some of them are going to
a concert and dancing or chatting with
friends and just having a good time
we see this as the next big changing
change in gaming and an epic's Evolution
as a company
you know we started out back in 1991
making 2D games uh we recognize the
opportunity with 3D so we vote the first
Unreal Engine and first Unreal
Tournament game we evolved to make
console games like Gears of War then we
evolved to make online games like
Paragon and fortnite
but when fortnite shipped first in 2017
it was just our game uh but over time we
recognized the audience the opportunity
to bring it to a much wider audience so
we built fortnite creative mode and then
the unreal editor for fortnite coming
out now but we see the future of this
medium primarily not about epic's work
but about the work of independent
creators
and we're building towards the sofa
metaverse from two different directions
first of all we're taking the fortnite
audience we have and enhancing the
development capabilities with the new
tools and this Creator economy to
support everybody's work
but we're also helping Developers
boning Standalone products evolve
towards building metaverse experiences
themselves the Unreal Engine is a tool
for this the epic game store is a
distribution vehicle for it epic online
services has taken fortnite an epic 700
million player accounts and 5 billion
social connections and open them up for
free to all developers so they can plug
into voice chat and participate in these
social experiences in a very easy to use
way and all of these are on-ramps to the
Future metaverse
we really think that over the next
decade today's separate apps and
ecosystems are going to join together to
form tomorrow's open metaverse
and yeah because the last couple decades
have been about wall Gardens wall
Gardens wall Gardens let's back up and
talk about how open systems have
successfully come about in the past you
know this has happened really big time
back in the early 1980s and 1990s when
the open internet was built
you know back in those days there were a
bunch of closed networks at different
companies and universities that couldn't
talk to each other
and so the industry got together and
defined Open Standards connect these
closed networks into one big open
network they connected email systems by
putting the at sign and email addresses
the people online service could
communicate with people on other
services
and then they began to Define Open
Standards like JavaScript and HTML for
the open internet so any user could
participate and the rule at that point
was that any company could connect as an
equal into this system just by following
the Open Standards
now let's talk about what this means for
the open metaverse of the future
you know we have the opportunity to take
all these different online ecosystems
for gaming consoles and Publishers and
connect them together into a single
place where anybody can talk to anybody
else
we have the opportunity to turn today's
game engines into tomorrow's metaverse
browser engines
if you take a look Unreal Engine and
unity and Godot you have some very
powerful 3D engines that have an
increasingly common set of features in
an increasingly adopting industry
standards as ways of communicating with
each other and with other tools there's
the glotf content standards there's
Pixar's Universal see in description
format and then there are a lot of new
standards bodies that have formed to
help to standardize the metaverse
there's Cronus group there's the
metaverse standards form there's the
academy software foundation and the open
3D Foundation
and we have the opportunity for all
developers to work together to define
the future of this thing
and there's also the opportunity to
connect the economies of these different
ecosystems you know what a user would
really like is to be able to buy a cool
looking outfit in one place and take it
everywhere they go
um and as we were designing this new
fortnite Creator economy one of the
things we were constantly thinking about
is how this could in the future be
connected into an open metaverse economy
and there's no reason that the core
model there in which revenue from item
shops are shared with creators of
experience based on engagement couldn't
be turned into an economic model for the
open metaverse at large with economic
peering and overseen by governance
groups to make this work in a safe way
for all players
and this gets us to a really key
question here and that is who is going
to build the metaverse in the future
and we believe the answer has to be all
of us together it has to be a
combination of indie game developers
together with double A and AAA game
developers and fortnite creators and
Minecraft creators and Roblox creators
each bringing their best specialized
knowledge to the to the new world and
Brands like Disney and Ferrari and Ralph
Lauren have already experienced the
metaverse through crossovers with
fortnite we think this is just the very
beginning of a very long-term
opportunity for all these companies tell
that if a much larger presence in the
digital world in which it becomes a
major and first class business line for
all of them uh future open metavers will
be about musicians and music labels and
film and television Studios who are
using virtual production today to build
world-class photorealistic content being
able to bring it and launch it playly in
the metaverse timed together with her
film and television experiences in an in
the Stream of awesome entertainment
content that's open to everybody to
participate in
now epic has a long history of
supporting developers this way you know
we've built a lot of different services
that are available to everybody to use
there's the Unreal Engine there's epic
online services which are open to all
platforms and all stores there's the
epic game store which is open to
software built on all engines using all
different online services and we believe
the metaverse has to be opened it can't
be another monopoly's wall Garden
and epic is all in on this you know we
went from the
uh you know we went from the pandemic to
the tech downturn the crypto implosion
and now banks are failing and it's a
really crazy time again but we're
investing very heavily in the future
with the belief that companies who
invest now through these hard times are
going to come out the strongest company
in the future become the strongest
companies in the future
some of these Investments we're making
in fortnite initially and then bringing
the work to Unreal Engine some things
were building an Unreal Engine taking to
fortnite but the aim is to support
everything the AAA game developers are
doing today and more
in this project to build this all out
into an open system is going to take
less than a decade and that is the
journey from Unreal Engine 5 to Unreal
Engine 6. that will happen over this
time period it is the same Journey to
the open metaverse but there's no need
to wait because we're doing it live
we're building all these systems and
deploying them as we build them right
into Unreal Engine 5 openly with
Partners so we hope you'll download this
stuff download on your editor for
fortnite download the Unreal Engine and
get started and come see some of our
Tech talks where you talk about this in
way more technical detail thank you very
much for your time
[Applause]